25 into Wednesday morning well the
building of the new and improved
westbound Lanes of Tropicana with the
I-15 going to start soon but by the way
have you seen the time lapse of how the
old outdated Lanes came tumbling down
thanks to the Nevada Department of
transportation's I-15 truck team it
starts at 10 p.m Friday January 27th
and
before you know it
the methodical takedown's done
with the cleanup underway by 10 Sunday
night
pretty amazing so the traffic in both
directions the 15th back up and running
by four o'clock the next morning Monday
morning the 30th by the way ooh are you
still getting used to that diverging
diamond on Trump maybe you're avoiding
Tropicana altogether let us know buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone here's the driving you crazy email
address we are traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com